ドライヤーの先端です
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
みなさん！さけるグミ
ってご存じでしょうか？
さいて食べるグミなんですけども
あれの　長いサイズのやつがでたみたいです
こちら
なが～～いさけるグミ
すごいですよ　これでほぼ原寸大
これくらいの長さのグミでございます
全長40センチ！！！
30センチみたいにメーターがふってあります
さけるグミの長いバージョン
ってことはすごいさけるってこと？
おおお！長い！
バンッ！
あ、やばい！
びっくりした 飛んでっちゃった
ムチみたいな威力があるんですけど
割いてみましょうか
わっ、こんな長さになります
んー。うまい。
ここで僕思ったんですけど
ま、４０CMを普通に売り出すとなると
一人でこれくらい食べるのが当たり前だなっ
て思ってこのぐらいにしたんですよね
つまり40cmが普通の食べる量だとすると
10メートルくらい食べれるんじゃないかなって思ったわけですよ
一回計算させてくれ。
これで40cmだから
というわけでまあまあまあこの僕なら余裕で食べれるんじゃないかなと思ったわけでございますよ
見栄えが悪いな
フッ
そもそもさけるグミって言うのは
割いて食べるんですよね、こういう
だから割いて、このちょびっとずつ
こうやってパクパク食べるのが割けるグミなんで
それをもう割かずに
何たる贅沢
もう何がなんでも食べます。
いただきます！
あ、、、全然余裕ですよ(｀・ω・´)
おいしい！
すごい
甘い
ちょっと想像の5倍くらい甘いですね
食べます
いやあちょっと思ったよりきついな。
味が受け付けないって言うか、まあ美味しいんですけど。同じ味ばっかりでちょっともう
無理だな
っていうのが本当のところです
スイマセンもう無理です。たぶんこれ以上食べると間違いなく
ただいま！
というわけで、はい！ちょっと時間を置いて帰ってきました
お腹はちょっと、だいぶ消化されて楽になったんですけど
ポイントがありまして
もうすごいっすよ。体の中が果樹園ですからね
味が飽きないように
残り4mちょい頑張っていきます。
いただきます！(☝︎ ՞ਊ ՞)☝︎
お腹はきついんですけど味の飽きはすごいです@(・●・)@
はい！
ラスト40cmです　いただきます！
完食！
あ、出た。やべえ
わたしもえびフィレオ食べたいなー(´・ω・｀)